boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on saki on we
are on site in Brooklyn in New York we
are going to be talking about all things
heart all things unity all things urban
wellness spirituality mental health and
well-being I'm super excited and
grateful and blessed to be sitting down
with Alexey Eden hello hi Alan thank you
so much for having me thanks for coming
on our show really appreciate it very
much looking forward to diving into all
the things yes there's lots of things
very pumped very pumped Alexa is an
urban wellness consultant and she's been
working with multiple clients over
multiple years on this and we're excited
to even you know to bridge the subject
of what this even is and also dive into
the nuance of why it's so important and
we're gonna start by explaining us on
like a big history level so ok we find
ourselves as stewards of Earth after
such a long period of evolution and
we're hockey sticking up in terms of our
population in terms of exponential
technology in terms of so many people
crammed into metropolis like Manhattan
and like these Chinese cities there's so
many people crammed into into these
network effect metropolis is slowing
down to tie ourselves into the heart
into nature into each other at a deeper
level is so important tell us more about
this whole idea of urban wellness
consulting absolutely so you say that it
is important and that is very true but
more than it being important is how we
do it so that's where I come in and
that's what I really stand behind is
really educating people on how to tap
into this power of our heart and our
communication and connection with others
in these metropolis cities the irony is
that we live among so many people and
yet we were desensitized to people so
how does that make sense where my work
comes into play is recognizing that as
human beings we have a responsibility to
our human capabilities and in that
process we give ourselves the abilities
and the tools to use technology to our
advantage
however we're at risk because as
technology advances and evolves we're
allowing it to control us so a lot of
the big conversation and and and the way
that we're really moving this narrative
is is when you start to recognize that
as human beings we have autonomy and
freedom to learn our capabilities we
start to break through this hold that
technology has on us and so a lot of the
conversation right now we've talked
about this before is that technology is
impacting our well-being well-being is a
really big umbrella statement it's not
really it's really pointing to anything
in specific when you start to dissect
well-being in the many different arenas
so that's mental well-being spiritual
well-being physical well-being social
emotional well-being those are all
really important components to us being
well human beings so I like to shine a
spotlight and all those individual
things and then kind of take it from
there I love how you're gonna walk us
through the importance of these
subcategories of well-being social
emotional mental spiritual physical all
of these are so crucial to unpacking
they're nuanced because breaking this
down into the nuance is crucial because
there's such deep to depth each one of
these and to like you said have these
have these as actionable things in this
urban environment to be really well okay
okay I also want to there's something
about this conversation that may be
slightly weird for people to potentially
feel that okay I'm desensitized why am I
being part of this descent
nice thing well we are all becoming more
desensitized because we are accidentally
dehumanizing each other we're
accidentally not living in our heart so
much
it's just our collective learning over
time and civilization has prioritized
the intelligence of the mind and the
intelligence of the math and the
language and the science and the history
and these sort of literature's those are
really important but we we weren't
prioritizing the emotional well-being
this heart centric well-being so they go
hand in hand so we're really adding the
heart centric well-being back into the
equation of civilization and technology
at a deeper level which is gonna help us
deal with that hockey-stick exponential
technology and and growth of population
and and now more than ever because as
technology is increasing at an
accelerated rate in our lives
human humanity needs to also be a player
so we need to learn these human
capabilities so we can actually use the
technology we have to increase at the
same speed at the same rate so I feel
that a lot of this heart stuff up until
recently hasn't really been given that
much leverage but the one thing that is
for sure is that AI no matter how smart
will never have a heart like we really
have it Wizard of Oz comes up for me
we're just speaking you'll never have a
real heart humans have such an amazing
capability and as we start to use
technology to take over some of our
simple tasks we're giving over our
freedoms in certain ways so knowing
where we can kind of take that back I
think it's important especially when we
live in urban cities because technology
is how we get around a lot of what I see
today people complain because the first
thing that they do in the morning they
wake up and they check their phone and
then they're constantly looking at
screens and what are they missing when
they're looking at their screens this
whole world around
and beauty of the whole world around
them and also tuning deep into their own
world inside of themselves with the
rapid access of oh I'm feeling like I'm
slightly bored oh I must tap into the
interwebs hava you tap into the trees
and the cars and the buildings and the
humans around you and your own emotional
state of how you're actually feeling in
that moment maybe you can gain some some
all and some bliss and some appreciation
for all the billions of humans that
built these structures that you now use
I mean I consider the amount of screen
time we all spend I don't even want to
say the average amount I'm 150 uses per
day yeah plus it's because we spend our
jobs also I was just gonna say that's
just our foments but what about our
computers No
so it's over eight hours consuming eight
hours consuming and what happens if you
keep stuffing things in your in your in
your laundry at some point it's not
gonna work anymore
so we're sitting here for hours on end
consuming and consuming consuming with
no outlet with no process time with no
creation so where does that leave us
it's like a really really important
thing to be talking about when we talk
about technology and how it's impacting
us as humans in a social and emotional
way so just taking one step backwards
for one second when we talk about
well-being and we make those
distinctions for a while
athleisure came out and that was cool
and then wellness came out and that was
green smoothies and and so when you
think of wellness the wellness industry
it's like green smoothies and yoga and I
am I got my great athleisure honors that
actual yogi that
from the east and it's like guys do yeah
and we're just like so but now the next
part is consciousness because now we
understand that wellness is important
but what is more than that consciousness
awakening awakening and then after that
it's human optimization because now once
we have the awareness now we can
optimize and what does that look like
and so now it's kind of this whole
journey and process and then that's on
an individual level but the way that an
individual who's now taken care of their
well-being in all areas and it is now
tapping into the consciousness and their
capabilities and then now is researching
ways to be optimized as a human being
how do they show up in the world how do
they show up in their families how do
they show up as a leader all these
things are really really crucial but
this is the conversation and it can't
just be a conversation has to start
going into education and so where are
the companies where are the big brands
what do they have to say about this it's
really important yes yes because the
fact is is that YouTube controls the
eyeballs the perception of two billion
human animals Facebook controls the
perception of two billion human animals
$0.10 does as well in China these are
tremendous numbers these are huge
numbers and there's a lot of
responsibility that comes with that much
power and where is the where is the
algorithm that sees me watching a guitar
video and says hmm Alan Alexa is a mile
nearby you she knows how to play guitar
you want to meet up with her you're
learning
looking looking at physics videos right
now do you want to go meet up with Eric
who studied physics he's half a mile
away from you gotta go
schedule a meeting with him walk over
there we have so much more power in what
this can actually do with tech human
human eye to eye and then we're missing
out on there's a lot of that happens
with the business plans and all this
other kind of stuff but you're so right
and they need to be leaders we need to
help them become leaders and we
ourselves and you become leaders you
mentioned this crucial importance of the
individual awakening and then helping
the family and community awaken and then
the earth awakened together so shall we
break down the process for one to all
the different wellness oh yeah I mean I
think even you know what does it look
like to take the reigns yeah of our time
of our well-being of our power of our
heart so consider that our hearts are
extremely intelligent organs so much so
that when you walk into a room and you
feel something's off it's not because
you think something's off it's because
you feel something is off so if if that
has any poll that means that we have a
responsibility to learn what this organ
is teaching us what is it saying and so
imagine if we start tapping into that
power we now are having a universal
conversation with the world I could be
anywhere and I could not speak the same
language as someone but if I'm tapped
into my heart space now we have a
conversation now we're connected
so one of the things I'm working on
right now I just quit quickly yeah I
think there's something really
interesting about the Hart's role in the
flesh vehicle that we live in in the
physical world because we have yet to
figure out exactly how much of this
consciousness how much of this love how
much of the stealing of the unity of
transcendence how much of that comes
from our heart these are very difficult
things like scientifically hypothesize
about and tap into but we are totally
getting there and it's really exciting
to see where we go with that and how
much our gut has to do with it or gods a
huge part of this too so it's all really
exciting that we just thought it was so
much on the brain but now we're really
digging into the brain the heart the gut
Center and figuring out this whole
intertwining of the whole biological
mechanism that we lived through giving
it a voice giving it a voice and it
takes quiet to give it a voice so it
means sliding off your screen going for
a walk turning out taking out your
headphones and listening it's that
simple it really is that simple but it's
scary because we don't do that anymore
so now you're talking to this new
stranger that just so happens to be
living in your heart and if we were in a
conversation right now I say this all
the time if we were in a conversation
right now
and you weren't listening at a certain
point I'd be like I'm fed up I'm not
talking to anymore
that's our heart so now years and years
and years of us being like we don't need
emotions emotions are bad for us let's
use technology and now all of a sudden
were so distance from this inner voice
that actually has our best interest at
heart no pun intended
so it's really it's really an
interesting it's an interesting
opportunity I think for us because it's
at a young stage we're at an inflection
point and we need the heart in order to
make it to the next stage as well to
make it there well it's it's a muscle
that needs to be trained the use of the
heart when when you're when we're just
reaching for the device when we're
disconnected from empathy and emotional
intelligence and love between humans
outside of our immediate social circles
of our families and whatnot that we have
to then go back and retrain because it
brought our experience our level or
experience points are very low our level
is very low from the birth of a child
and we must start training that muscle
and leveling up that character that
experience point that that that
attribute of the heart strength leveling
that up really quickly and then that
will help lead us into where we'd like
to see things move okay shall we I just
have to say one of it yeah so what the
whole nights been I just have to say
this just one thing it's all great to
sit in quiet and listen to our heartbeat
and like love everyone and feel
connection and unity it's great I love
it but how is it practical right that's
everyone's real question how does this
make sense in my life why is it worth my
time why is it worth my energy why is it
worth my investment the point is is that
we are humans on this planet and in
order to make a difference in order to
keep it going around we have to strike a
balance between accelerated technology
and slow living we're on this planet
with the noodles and noodles of
technology and we still need to learn
how to live in our most human way so
living slowly being
connected to an earth being connected to
each other turning off for a second
finding that peace living in the garden
of life so striking a balance so that
way we can actually be are up to my self
is important because I love the idea of
sitting on a mountain chillin and
meditating all day meditation station
but how do i infuse it into the world
how do I bring the spirituality that I
experience in my meditation I can share
it because it's not just for me it's
route reality is for the world for all
of us to learn and to connect with them
to love so how do we bring that down
luckily for me I've caught wind of this
fairly early and I've been using and you
too
I've been using the tools of technology
to share this spirituality this
consciousness this education this wisdom
and and and that's the beauty of it but
there's this really delicate balance
it's important for us to really start to
recognize how can integrate this yeah I
want you to jump into how to integrate
it you use strike a balance love that so
much super fast paced tech slow down
connect to yourself connect to others
connect to earth and also you ask what's
the practicality the practicality is
leaving a gorgeous positive wake and
aura everywhere you go it's amazing the
butterfly effect just goes just start
doing everywhere
your smile your groundedness your love
that you radiate goes everywhere yeah
it's true
radiation in the best way possible out
of that right let's do the breakdown
integrating yes so to break down these
five elements of well-being I first
start with physical well-being we need
to be physically well in order to bring
our light into the world so what we know
that as is exercise
yoga stretching nutrition touch physical
touch is really important and then we
talk more about mental well-being to
give our mind a break to recharge it to
slow things down to see things clearly
we don't give ourselves those
opportunities but what does it look like
when we do when you have clarity when
you're not pulled in a million
directions in today's age we are
constantly inundated with information it
doesn't stop dings and sounds and noises
and notifications and vibrations and and
billboards and lights and it's
exhausting so we talk about mental
well-being there's a big difference
between Mel - albeit mental well-being
and mental illness as all things there
is the consistent upkeep and then
there's when there's a problem there's
something to do mental well-being is an
opportunity for us to take care of these
things that give us so much insight it's
so so so important when we talk about
wellness and well-being next is
spiritual so now we've taken care of our
body our body has been a great space or
head now we're taking care of it we've
given it quiet
we've recharged it we've cleared it out
of all the noise and now spiritually we
give ourselves the opportunity to
connect with that deeper self to connect
with that purpose to connect with each
other in that type of way there's that
there's that that universe that connects
us that oneness and when we exist
they're just a lot less disagreement
because it speaks
same language so now we're doing pretty
good feeling good we're taking care of
ourselves and then what comes next
emotional wellness emotional wellness is
key because now I'm in touch with myself
I've given myself that space to
spiritually connect my purpose is what's
my passion what lights me up in the
world
those are all incredible things and now
emotionally I get to connect with myself
and I get to connect with others I get
to have empathy I get to be there with
people unfortunately what we're finding
is that technology is putting up this
barrier it's distracting ourselves from
ourselves and because we don't know
ourselves we can't know each other so we
start looking at how technology is
impacting our emotional well-being it
goes deeper than look at her life it's
so nice look at that vacation it's great
I don't have as many friends out of a
followers making likes so much deeper
than that and those things are all
happening it's important that we talk
about that as well what we really the
next thing we need to talk to start
discussing and educating on is that our
emotional well-being exists inside us
how comfortable are we with ourselves to
embrace the human emotions that occur if
I have my screen up at all times I don't
have to feel any emotion I don't want to
feel because I can watch that cat video
and I can watch that scary movie and I
can watch that sitcom and I anything I
want to see it's right there for me I
can buy that thing I can order this now
I can it's all there but when you
silence that and you put that aside give
yourself this opportunity to connect
with that self feel those emotions
recognize them understand what it's
doing
for you and when you see a friend in
turmoil you're able to be with them in
that instead of just feeling lost over
with no emotions so that's emotional
wellness really important also see you
know we have all these different
categories of wellness that up until now
like are not really talked about so now
we talk about social wellness and social
wellness is really important as well we
hear the buzzwords like Community
Connection authenticity great words
powerful words if we know how to use
them in our lives
community isn't about showing up at a
place to be seen it's about allowing
yourself to be yourself in a place with
others who see you as that self which is
really powerful but the world wasn't
built on its own we need each other we
need to be with each other we need to
understand each other and so community
gives us that opportunity
so social wellness is encouraged when we
show up in these places when we connect
with others when we when we learn about
new cultures and new ideas and we we
step out of ourselves and our worlds and
how we see everything and we enter this
world of connection and when we're in a
world of connection things are a lot
more bright and beautiful and happy but
if all I'm doing is not paying attention
to the social needs
I'm just isolating myself and it's hard
to do it's hard to live good healthy
well life if you're doing that so five
really important distinctions and I
could talk about it forever when we'll
leave that there and we can all let it
settle
damn the breakdown
you can tell it's so much deeper than
how we've been giving it credit for
cuz up until now I'm telling you you
here wellness you think smoothie and
yoga I'm not the only one people like I
don't have time for wellness I'm
building a company I'm a CEO I'm a
scientist I'm researching I don't have
time for these things but we're human
beings all of us are and when we take
care of ourselves in the many different
dimensions that we need to be taken care
of we show up show up alive we show up
connected we show up with passion and
that's what's going to change our world
we need that I don't have to tell you
that I know you know that it's maybe I
have to tell you guys that I'm I'm
always a work in progress we're always a
work in progress all of us we're
enjoying the progress of being process
we're enjoying the process of being a
work in progress
all of us it's really important to do
the breakdown and to really feel the
breakdown and sink in because it gives
perspective on the dimensions that we
may not be giving enough of our time to
but you can't blame us right because why
would we take the time when it's all
literally why take the time why take
that because taking the time has a
compounding effect on all of the huh
you know okay you can't do things a
little bit differently you can engage
with the technology you can engage with
the business you can engage with humans
in more advanced ways by slowing down
and tuning in word and working on the
well-being okay I got it I gotta test
myself
hmm as you know I like to paraphrase to
show that I've learned so let's see if I
can do this all right
okay so physical wellness stretching
yoga nutrition taking breaks away from
computer screens breaks away from
hitting the phone up okay
mental mental well-being
mental well-being is knowing our thought
processes our habits
knowing our worldview being very tight
tightly tied into our truth true
understanding of that looking at
ourselves well in the mirror spiritual
well-being connecting to something
greater than ourselves transcending
ourselves connecting to that divine
spirit within ourselves and within all
of us with our heart to that love and
consciousness that's permeates
everything that we can embody and unite
with okay and then emotional well-being
so the emotional well-being is that we
know our own feeling we give space for
our own feeling we can tune into our own
feeling and give space for the feeling
of other people around us our friends
our families our co-workers even people
on the street that we can give space and
see people and have be seen by people in
Archer authentic selves and lastly
social well-being socially we want to we
want to build really authentic and
genuine heart centric relationships with
our families with our co-workers and our
friends and that social well-being is
crucial for building our networks in
terms of what we care about building
what we find most meaningful to surround
ourselves with those people so I'm gonna
grade myself at 20% no that was great we
I'm a harsh critic on myself
I gave myself 20% I got work to do but
but even having the breakdown of the
five is so crucial yeah totally yeah
physical mental spiritual emotional
social well-being having that breakdown
in mind is really crucial the only way
we talk about this a lot the only way
for us to make progress towards these
new ways of thinking these new
awarenesses is to create these
breakdowns to create these in the
ologies UM's these new words these new
ways of thinking and breaking things
down which have likely already been
developed by civilizations in the past
and put into books and put into practice
and then forgotten we see a lot of that
with some of the tibetan buddhist
traditions and whatnot there's a lot of
deep connection to oneself that one
practices throughout their life so which
the rebirth thing and they're
resurfacing of these really crucial
wisdoms in the technology age to strike
that balance I will say it was it was
that a question it was me scoring myself
20% I'm paraphrasing way more than 20%
you did great and it's a process a good
teacher I will say that it's not just
about us forgetting but all of a sudden
you have this new shiny toy that comes
in it does everything and it's never
over and I can just play with it all the
time why would I redo this ancient book
who cares why would I deal with the
complex emotions inside of my own body
into someone else's body yeah why
because I've got this shiny shiny new
toy the endless variable rewards like
it's a hijacking of the mind dopamine
yeah so I want to talk about really
quickly the practicality of all this
urban wellness stuff true right because
obviously we want to show up as our
whole selves as we talked about and it's
true what does it look like and how do
we do it so being able to integrate
practices into your daily life or your
weekly life or your monthly life you
hear lis whatever it is allows us the
opportunity to cater and nurture these
elements of our life so daily meditation
practice is not always easy but when you
couple your meditation practice
something else that you like or
something else that you do daily all of
a sudden now you're killing two birds
one stone
we all like to do that we live in the
city we've got things to do so one of
the things that I started doing for
myself and what I recognized was that
the commuting time on average Americans
spent two hours commuting a day so that
time could be used really wisely instead
of sitting there scrolling on Instagram
or on Facebook or messaging podcasts
Arkwright what if we saw sort of
thinking about that time is our time to
recharge how could we show up at home if
after a long stressful day at work you
get to go home to your family you get to
talk to your roommates and you get to be
present with that you get to leave work
at home you get to leave work at work
and show up at home but we're in this
constant connectivity that we never get
a break and that's exhausting so we've
looked at it all day come home why don't
we do we watch Netflix cuz what else
would we do
now we watch Netflix before we go to bed
or just gonna check our email and then I
go to bed because I'm thinking about all
the things I have to do the next day
three years go by well
that's intense but it's real so
integrating small things into your life
in a daily basis will be really helpful
in making changes making important
significant changes so I stopped wearing
headphones because for me that allows me
to connect to my world I get to hear the
birds tripping on the street I get to
hear different languages on the subway
so give yourself the opportunity to tune
into your world and the more you do that
the more you start to feel connected and
the more user doesn't recognize this
world is actually really beautiful even
with the darkness and the sadness and
the struggles and the changes there's a
lot going on but there's beauty too and
we're missing that the practicality of
applying urban wellness to our lives
goes taps into every single aspect of
what we do it's super practical it's
super clickable and all of us want the
best for ourselves and our families and
our communities people around us
everywhere even the ones walking across
the street that we don't know up until
now we don't know how yeah we may even
be that we really well practice this in
more ancient times and the shiny object
the endless stream of dopa mean yeah the
shiny object takes us away from the
practices totally and wish shiny objects
the shiny objects now I have a watch and
I have a phone and I have a talent I
have a computer and I've got the TV and
I've got a lek so over there over there
she's amazing
Alexa is amazing Alexa her and just be
Dennis that's so funny
okay let's transition to the war on tech
hold up before you even think about it
technology has enabled us to do
incredible things throughout our lives
it's super cool that we can just call
each other across the world and video
chat amazing we also have to acknowledge
the fact that during the Cold War we
almost had mutually assured destruction
twice and then we dropped a bomb two
bombs on Hiroshima and Nagasaki
after the bombing of Pearl Harbor but
regardless this is some really there's
been a technology can be used in so many
different ways in surgical applications
for extending people's lives giving them
more time with their families and
creative creative time the application
of technology for all the human
flourishing is incredible and we do want
that to be well known like thank you
that is amazing bless all the people
that have made this technology
electricity fridges the ubiquity and all
the things we have thank you thank you
traveling across the world in just a
couple hours via plane whoa but on the
same conversation point we must address
the nuance of where technology has
caused quite a bit of malevolence mental
health issues addiction take away so
it's a tool technology has always been a
tool whether it was a spear made out of
a stone that was technology it was a
tool it had a purpose today we have
technology it has a purpose but when we
start to give our freedoms away to the
tools
that run our life we lose our sense and
our power as humans so thinking about it
as like a war might be dramatic but it's
important to recognize that we are at
war with our technology every single
second of the day we just strike the
balance strike the balance it's really
really important I recognized in my
modern life how hard it is to actively
choose to strike a balance day in and
day out there's always something else
pulling me and I'm conscious of this so
imagine now you have no idea that
there's even this issue going on and you
wonder why you're tired why you feel
alone
all these things it's because we're not
aware of the impact it's making on us so
use it use it as a tool use it when you
need it and if you're not sure what you
need it for and why you're using it turn
it off you'll know why
oh I haven't called my mom today that's
a good reason to use your phone totally
call your mom if you're reaching for it
because you don't want to talk to that
person you don't want to make eye
contact with that person you any number
of reasons that is a red flag and so it
is very valuable to turn off the phone
and to see how how are feeling what's
coming up and take note
and we mentioned this earlier hmm it's
and we have some cool social experiments
we've been talking about but this is
totally a responsibility of ourselves
the grassroots this feeling from within
ourselves and bring it out the
well-being across all those dimensions
simultaneously it's a responsibility of
the massive technology companies that
have now found themselves as the biggest
influencers on society even more so than
took over the banks in the last 10 years
is the largest influencers of society
same goes in China and the other parts
of the world and now it's their
responsibility as well to help us with
the mental health and well-being
spiritual actualization social
actualization etc in our lives it's
their responsibility simultaneously and
it would be more powerful to see it come
from within the corporations in my
opinion than it would be to see it come
from government regulations we want to
see it come from within the hearts of
the executive leadership at these
companies and from the grassroots
leadership at these companies rather
than have a government regulation strike
down to say that they have to behave
this way it's much better to come from
within so it's two-sided it's from us
from our own selves and us as well as
from the ones that are providing these
technology services both I mean you talk
about this all the time but it's really
what is the future of the planet look
like with such an increase in the
population it's so many eyes on these
apps and channels and platforms there is
a need and an opportunity and a
responsibility more than all of those
things to recognize the impact that
these tools are having and to do
something about it it's great that the
people who started all this technology
won't let their kids use it that's
awesome but what about the rest of the
people on the planet
that doesn't matter those people don't
matter so I agree with you there is a
responsibility of leadership both within
ourselves and with the corporation's to
make a difference to make an impact and
we've been now aligning some of the
solutions we have this LinkedIn the bio
for you to check out Alexa has a great
video called transformation
transportation and it's very short just
one minute it's super powerful thank you
it's very very powerful
thank you we're about to have meditation
cars trains airplanes these heart
centric environments for people to
connect themselves and others in these
hours that we spend transiting teach us
about this so I'll tell you what really
made me conceptualize this movement
I was sitting on the subway car as
normal and someone comes on to the train
and they say excuse me ladies and
gentlemen I'm sorry to interrupt but as
of yesterday my house burned down my
three girls my wife we're out of
everything we have no furniture we have
enough with no clothes and if there's
anyone who has anything to provide or
share or give we would be really really
appreciative and it was like my biggest
fear had just happened in front of my
eyes because nobody on the train was
done not only did they not look up they
didn't even flinch
they didn't even hear it so I'm like
this is what I was hoping wouldn't
happen we're so disconnected from each
other
we're so glazed over no one's saying
that we had to hand over the shirt off
our back but no one could even
acknowledge his pain his struggle wish
him luck acknowledge him look at him so
there's this awful feeling how broken we
are broken it is so in that moment on
that train I'm looking at this something
has got to change
so I notice that if you're not sitting
on the subway with your headphones in
you would have at least heard it and you
would have at least felt something and
what happened to that feeling what do
you do with that and when you feel
feelings you either
stuff it away or you recognize this is a
really powerful feeling what is it
telling me what can I learn from it why
am I feeling this way
why am I feeling this way there's so
much going on in our hearts they were
not giving any attention so I decided to
redesign the commuter experience to use
that time as a time to tap in to pay
attention to listen to yourself to
connect with the people around you and
to use that time as a powerful and
consistent because you're commuting
daily time to practice presence to
practice connecting with yourself
connecting with others and being there
for each other
so transformation transportation was
built and designed for humans to get
their heart back and this is just the
beginning because the the way that we
show up when we do that consistently the
way it compounds in our lives and it
makes a difference we show up to work
happier we're able to deal with other
people around us that usually challenge
us differently we get to leave the drama
at work or at home there and we could
just show up at our new destination as a
different person as a that true person
we want to be so we have power it starts
here it's a choice then it's a practice
then it's a conversation and then it's a
movement
the practicality is wise it's quite a
simple roadmap the first thing is that
conscious choice that conscious choice
when we are there basically in the train
car doing the transit in the car and the
plane in the morning when we wake up
before we grab the phone check in with
ourselves checked in with how we're
feeling checking with our environment
look at the other humans around us take
some deep breaths close our eyes feel
our bodies that conscious choice leads
to everything else pretty much going
really well after that point but we have
to keep practicing that conscious choice
and we have to practice going into the
zones of fear there was a really good
sign in Manhattan on a big garage near
the your the financial district that
said acknowledge the fear and then do it
anyway do it anyway yeah yeah it's such
a good one and so we continue the
practice of consciously making the
choice acknowledging that yeah this
might be uncomfortable but I'm gonna go
talk to the guy that literally just said
that he's home burned down and we're
gonna work that muscle if the heart work
that muscle the emotional intelligence
and well-being work that muscles connect
you know there are humans and bonus
working that muscle will help you out
pace the rate of automation yes at least
you will be at the very end of the time
period of automation taking over most of
our work so work out that heart centric
muscle so there's a bonus all right
let's let's talk about this yes okay you
just came back from Israel how long ago
probably two weeks at this point okay so
Alexa was in Israel in January yes of
2019 and she experienced Shabbat she
experienced a bunch of interesting
things while you were there they've just
groundedness to such an ancient area
with so much civilizational history
teach us okay so it's hard to say in a
few short words but what I will say and
share is that to the depth that we give
ourselves the opportunity to explore
ourselves is how we will connect with
spirituality it's within us and it
expands above us so it takes time it
takes choice it takes practice and it
takes presence so learning that there's
this
there's more going on than we realize
it's so easy to get caught up in our day
to day one thing to the next that we we
very rarely stop and take a step back
and look around one of the things that I
love and I hold on to so much is this
concept of Shabbat because God created
the world in six days and then on the
seventh he took a step back and he
looked at it he said isn't this place
great and if he did that
why wouldn't we what makes us better
that we can't stop that we have to do
more then we always have to be because
all artists need to take a step back and
look and it's in those moments when you
stop it's the clarity the dust settles
there's not so much noise but you get
this incredible foresight into what our
reality is offering us and then you go
back to it with all this renewed energy
which is incredible yeah that's a huge
lesson to take away from Judaism as well
as other practices around the world work
on things like fasting things like
prayer connecting to something that
transcends you something divine I would
like to say God in in many ways is so
interesting seeing people talk about God
from different religions but then not
want to sort of talk to the other one
about what their God is because this God
that is thrown around so much whether it
be six days and seventh day of rest and
like oh this is amazing
whether it just be all that is jihad
being all that is everything everything
that that connects us all that that
connects us all and I want to say
Shabbat is very interesting cuz Shabbat
is its rest or a cessation and this is
actually a major practice in
conscientiousness as well is when you're
you know when you're done on on Friday
evening with some of your hustle you're
just like yo until Saturday night I'm
not going to touch my work stuff I'm
gonna actually focus on these five
dimensions of well-being and you
actually follow through and you do that
and then Saturday night comes around and
you're like damn I'm hella refresh I'm
super ready to get back at it and so the
more that you set these goals for
yourself and work on this conscientious
muscle as well with this well-being
muscle you set these goals and you
actually achieve them the stronger you
will become at everything you set your
mind to it's so so crucial goal-setting
and execution especially with resting
it's you will help you a lot to want to
tell your 8 hours of sleep gotta do it
gotta do it
exercising I gotta do it meditating I
gotta do it and set these things up and
go and do them bonding with some random
person because you want to ask them a
question and become a little
uncomfortable and test it out you got to
do you got to set these goals you got to
try you got to do it there's different
colors on the color of people can have
different lives they can choose what
they want to do also just quitting a lot
of the toxic habits that we have the
toxic habit of constantly needing to
connect and check and all that stuff
the constant habit of wanting to
distract ourselves with the next the
next drug the next alcohol the next the
next cannabis the next LSD or psilocybin
or their DMT or
the next dopamine hits there they're
just the it's like
it feels good it is a drug and Satguru
is one of my favorite quotes about it
he's like he's like I never do drugs but
I'm always high that's right that's
right that's right that's how we do it
like that that's how we do it because
you can totally have he also says every
breath is ecstasy and this of course is
much harder to have every breath be
ecstasy when you don't have clean water
and etc so that's why we're raising the
baseline of living across the planet as
soon as possible so for me Shabbat has
served as a tool a tool to strike a
balance between technology and slow
living because it's in those moments of
slow living I optimized myself to use
technology in the physical space to
optimize my reality
so it's this incredible dance that when
you tap into your spiritual potential
you have more clarity on how to use the
technology you use it it doesn't use you
and you move forward it's incredible the
better you get at the strike of balance
dance the more effectively you realize
your fullest potential into the world
yes it's fact I agree with that been
trying to preach it in non in the not
nuanced descriptive way that you've been
preaching it I really like that but that
break down is really crucial I must
start using it more often
coming at you coming at myself too I'm
working on this okay last couple
questions on the way out
let's start with what is your superpower
so I've been holding this very near and
dear to my heart
what's a very so interesting about the
work I'm doing is that right now the
name Alexa is the pinnacle of Technology
everyone's got an Alexa that's
technology Eden just my middle name like
the Garden of Eden it's the slowest most
peaceful place and what's fine to me is
that this duality exists in the essence
of my name and I'm using technology to
bring peace into the world to bring this
peace of mind this Garden of Eden
lifestyle to our modern world
so it's this essence that I'm existing
in and I want to say that my superpowers
peace and I feel really good about that
my superpowers peace
that's so funny that your name is
basically strike a balance get to be the
pinnacle of tech and they call miss yes
a very cool place I love that that's so
funny it's interesting and I live in
Manhattan which is like this one so not
the place of and you have helped run a
festival that goes out into the middle
of nature and immersion and stuff so
again you yeah yeah that contrast as
well it's good that you picked peace as
a superpower I love that
and also I'm obsessed with World Peace
obsessed obsessed we're so going to get
there okay next question what would you
say is a core driving principle of your
life oh that's a good one
a core driving principle in my life
fulfillment
taking an untraditional entrepreneurial
route has taught me the value of
fulfillment in a ways that I wouldn't
have otherwise experienced if I was
caught up in all the other things I
could be measuring my life in years
numbers bank accounts a whole number of
things but throughout all of it what
I've come to learn is that fulfilment is
the most special thing that you can have
in a moment in a relationship in a
project in a movement in a conversation
anything I think that that really drives
me and if you could rebuild civilization
from scratch how would you design it
lots of plants a lot of plants delicious
smells really good food gotta have good
food
and creative expression I think we're
lacking that I think I think technology
can oftentimes get in the way of our
creativity and I think it's a really
important process for human beings so I
would want there to be this con this set
up for creativity where people could
feel free to express themselves in any
way they wanted because coming from a
world before I knew what self-expression
was I thought I was expressing myself
and then I learned all the things that I
didn't say that I wanted to say that I
could have said but I was afraid to say
because they didn't want to hurt that
person because I didn't want to look
that way I didn't want them to think
that way of me that's a lot of not
self-expression but then you learn to do
it and you realize what if we could all
do that what if we could all express
ourselves freely powerfully meaningfully
productively I would want to build a
civilization built on that absolutely
that's like the pinnacle civilization is
where all our being creatively expressed
to their fullest like that a lot
how about we ask you tell us about what
you've connected to that's past this 3d
reality I close my eyes because for me I
want to make sure that I am not
distracted by my surroundings in my
responses and I feel that every question
has its own it's its own power and how
it impacts me and my process and to
reflect on a time where I connect it to
something outside of this 3d reality
I would say I was in Jerusalem and I was
meditating at my hotel and I felt this
really powerful vibration all up and
down way back and I never felt that
before and it was like I welcomed it I
embraced it it was a little bit
overwhelming because I was like this is
new and at the same time I didn't feel
afraid
I felt secure and connected
this is what we can feel when we tap
deeply into ourselves and how we are
connected to everything and it's a
profound awareness shift how about do
you think this is a simulation I'm like
this place right now where we are oh let
me change the code quick yeah change the
cards I got it I haven't given it much
thought
when I think about it I choose not to
because I don't think that helps for me
I don't think that it provides value
maybe it is and maybe it's not
we may know soon enough we may know all
right
last question okay what is the most
beautiful thing in the world
Oh
I would say looking into someone's eyes
so deeply that you see them for all that
they are when you are so present and so
connected and you're really with someone
the most beautiful thing there's just
it's a it's a palpable it's it's a
special moment and I think it's the most
beautiful
the research is becoming more and more
clear that by taking these really long
periods of time to look at someone
else's eyes so really intimately and try
and see them for a whole that they are
and they see you for all that you are
holy cow the interconnectedness just
just skyrockets really yeah it's just
you do
oxytocin flow there's no feeling of both
I hate you even if this is a maybe a
conservative and a liberal or maybe
someone from China and some from the US
or whatever it may be so because you
that is another part of the what's
beyond the 3ds what's what's embodying
the what spirits embodying the flesh
vehicles right now tap into that better
can we understand that better green
polka with a scientific tool hypothesize
me holy cow this is been epic previously
I have a feeling it would be that this
was super epic yeah yeah means you had a
feeling and ended up being super epic
yeah yeah I'll exit thanks for joining
us on the show thank you for having me
thank you for having me I think I should
call you Eden now yeah it's like the
Train cool like I would love that I'm
transitioning to eat in I love it yeah
it's like so yeah it's beautiful
thank you yeah I feel like I need a hug
you instead of shake your hand
what I'm keep up the good work thank you
give up the good work
miss Eden was a good work thank you for
creating this platform this platform is
meant for people like you good job good
job everyone thank you so much for
tuning in and greatly appreciate it we
would love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below give us your thoughts
above to start a conversation about
these topics also go and check out some
of Alexa even's work with the links
below go and check it out
also we would love to request everyone
to start having more conversations about
these five breakdowns of well-being and
this urban wellness let's really start
having these conversations amongst each
other grassroots the movement up through
ourselves as well as get some of the
tech powers to help as well
strike the balance strike a balance
everyone much love keep supporting other
people like Alexa epic people like us we
can continue doing cool things like
coming on-site took cool places like New
York and doing interviews much love
everyone build the future manifest your
destiny into the world to its fullest
much love we'll see you soon
that was good we talked about a lot of
things thank you clothes you're like
you're just like flow and let's go